we're going to begin this hour with
another big story two years in the
making the emotional toll of the
pandemic on health care workers after
these two years of incredible stress a
recent study found that one in five
nurses say they are burned out some say
they struggle to eat to sleep and to
stay healthy themselves in a recent
survey an astounding 68 percent of
nurses have said they considered leaving
their jobs we spoke with five health
care workers all around the country
about the stress they face while on the
front lines
[Music]
working in healthcare is definitely a
marathon and it seems worse now you
don't get enough sleep
you're not eating and you're you're
working shift after shift it's just
exhaustion i might sleep for like four
hours
i kept replaying today over and over
again did i turn this off did i do this
correctly thinking back to march of 2020
i did not think we would still be here
now
the er that i work in we have 50 beds
that we can see patients in and we are
seeing
our senses at any given time is a
hundred so double the what we actually
have capacity for i come home from work
and there's days where my scrub top is
covered in sweat as soon as i'm walking
out of work because we're hustling you
know the entire 12 hours
you're seeing more death and dying than
ever before and that's hard and we are
people we're humans and we need time to
grieve too
when you're busy and your hospital is
bursting at the seams you don't have
that time you just have to go on and
take care of the next patient
the burnout has been around the
inability to get ahead of it so in
healthcare we're so used to being able
to get ahead of different things and a
lot of times we haven't been able to do
that because 19.
the most difficult part of
this whole pandemic for me has been
losing colleagues and friends to
different jobs or different
opportunities or to the burnout itself
i have friends that have gotten
completely out of nursing you've got a
shortage of workers you've got lots of
people out because they're quarantining
and so you you're having to pick up
extra in overtime in order to take care
of patients
we need more nurses in the workforce
[Music]
i got very lucky that my fiance does the
same job i do we work side by side every
day every shift we work is together it
definitely helps to have somebody who
fully understands
what i'm going through
i had that heart-to-heart conversation
with my husband and i told him that this
is what i love this is what i want to do
because i was on the fence of if i was
going to continue with this all
healthcare workers right now should
reach out and
be willing to open up to their
colleagues
to their friends to their families
that when they're feeling that burnout
we're so used to taking care of other
people we tend not to take care of
ourselves as much
[Music]
senior medical correspondent dr taran
narula joins us now uh dr naruella it's
powerful interviews there uh with
frontline workers they're all
experiencing some degree of burnout what
are the effects of burnout well i think
it's important that we say a lot of
people think this is a fluffy term but
actually in 2019 the world health
organization created a diagnosis code
for this and they call it an
occupational phenomenon and the roots of
burnout trace back to the 1970s when a
psychologist here in new york city was
volunteering at free clinics down in the
east village that were treating those
with drug addiction and he recognized in
himself and his staff what was happening
that they were really giving so much of
themselves they were becoming
emotionally depleted and they were
having a lot of the signs of what he
termed burnout he took that term from
the addiction community and then in the
1980s another psychologist expanded on
this christina maslak and actually
created what's now a burnout inventory
the mbi and that's how we grade it and
so we look at three main things it's
kind of characterized by emotional
exhaustion dissatisfaction with your
personal accomplishments and
depersonalization you're not connecting
with your patients the problem with all
this is that for healthcare workers it
really strips them it colors their world
the way that they see things the way
they interact with the world it takes
away hope and interest and joy and it
sets them up for things like substance
abuse depression suicide problems in
their relationships you know it's been a
couple of years you first did this story
a couple years ago where you focused on
the um the exhaustion of the medical
community i swear to you tara i never
even thought of that until you brought
it to our attention it it hurts that two
years later we are still having the same
conversation so what can hospitals do
what can they do what should they do to
address what is happening to health care
professionals and how tired and
exhausted and burned out they feel
because we need them absolutely and it
is a resource in our country that is
depleted right now and it was a crisis
that existed before covid we know that
one-third to one-half of health care
workers reported a burnout before covin
clearly that has increased now and i
remember we interviewed someone a year
or two ago a healthcare worker who said
he feels like a rope frayed at both ends
there was a recent article about burnout
that called it death by a thousand cuts
and that's really what it is you know
burnout when you ask healthcare workers
a lot of it is the administrative burden
the bureaucracy of charting and
paperwork but then add to that what's
happened this past two years right so
they're overwhelmed long hours staff
calling out staff sick and they're
filling in they had fear of being sick
themselves or bringing it home to their
family so what should hospitals do well
hospitals need to play a role in this
the leadership needs to create positions
like chief wellness officers they need
to create peer support groups they need
to create a culture where mental mental
health is okay to speak up about that
people won't feel penalized for talking
about it and they really need to create
resources flexible schedules even hazard
pay and bonuses so there's a lot that
leadership can do as well as individuals
yeah another reason why we should check
on each other especially the heroes that
work in healthcare that's right thank
you so much terry you're the best